My name's Kevin Harrison,
and I'm the owner and
operator of Project Laser,
which is a mobile laser-cleaning service
in Western Australia.
Lasers are really good at cleaning soot
off basically any hard substrate.
So that can be a wooden beam,
a steel beam, a painted wall,
paving stones, bricks,
all sorts of surfaces,
whether it's really smooth or porous.
We're sending thousands of
light pulses every second
into the surface contamination.
This is getting absorbed into the soot,
and it's basically vaporizing it
or popping it off the surface.
On this day, we were called in to help out
remove smoke damage from a home
that had a Molotov
cocktail thrown into it.
There was smoke filled throughout the home
on both stories.
Like, really, really dark black soot,
and we had to remove smoke damage
from every single surface.
So this was within the kitchen,
lounges, bathrooms.
We used our large laser for this job,
because it's got the 15-meter hose.
We parked the vehicle
right next to the house
and then just extended
the fiber-optic cable
through a door that had been kicked in.
And that gave us access to
the majority of the house.
This was a really long process.
Basically worked from left to right.
Once we finished laser cleaning,
we did wipe down the walls just to ensure
there's no vagrant soot on the surface.
We use a pulse laser,
which is basically a tool
to remove thin layers of
surface contamination.
So, the benefits of a pulse laser,
it has no abrasive power.
So no matter how hard we try,
we can't profile, scratch,
or damage a surface.
Porous brick is going to
absorb more of the soot.
It's got all the cracks and crevices
where soot will sit, and you may have to
clean at certain different angles,
whereas if you've got a nice,
smooth, painted surface,
it's all even, there's no soot
hiding in different cracks and crevices.
Here we're doing smoke-damage removal
with our small 200-watt mobile laser
on a rammed-earth wall.
If you'd run your fingers over the wall,
it was all crumbly and falling apart.
So if they'd chosen to
use high-pressure water,
chemicals, and scrubbing brushes,
they would've removed lots of material.
This was a bush fire that basically
came up to the home and licked the wall
and then caught the trusses on fire.
So there was also some
smoke-damage cleaning
inside the house that we had to carry out.
When you're using a
laser-cleaning machine,
you need to take safety very seriously.
It is very easy to mitigate the risks.
Firstly, that can be done
by wearing the correct safety glasses.
So for us, that's wearing safety glasses
that protect your eyes from the
1,064 infrared laser pulses.
Secondly, we've spent
an uncomfortable amount
of money on respirators.
So everyone who operates the laser
will be wearing a respirator.
The beautiful thing about
using a laser-cleaning machine
is you can really adjust the parameters
depending on what you're cleaning.
If you want to clean
a larger area quicker,
you can have a beam that goes,
for example, 100 millimeters wide,
or about 3½ inches.
If you wanted to do large areas,
you could turn the power
up and have a large beam.
And at the same time,
you could really wind the power down
if you wanted to remove
soot off a chandelier
or a bathtub or the side of a TV.
You really could wind it down enough
to not damage even plastics, if necessary.
With our smaller laser,
it's got a really defined focal zone,
an inch or a couple centimeters.
So if you're not perfectly
within that focal zone,
the laser's not going to
be effectively cleaning.
The beauty of the laser
is you can just move
backwards and forwards slowly,
and you'll hear when the
laser is at its loudest,
which is basically when it's
chewing through the soot.
You could laser clean
with your eyes closed
and just use your ears
once you get used to the sound.
On this job, we're using our 500-watt
laser-cleaning machine
to remove smoke damage
from a pool pump that caught on fire.
Once we arrived on site,
we saw that we could easily put
our fiber-optic cable over the fence.
Unfortunately, there was a
lot of heat with this fire,
so there was a bit of
area where the bricks
were permanently oxidized.
So there was a fair few spots
where there's actually
permanent damage on the bricks.
We took off all the
old plug points, screws
that were still stuck in the wall.
This just enabled us
to really clean the whole wall properly.
If we need to protect any hoses or cables
when we're laser cleaning,
put blue masking tape over the surface,
or ideally you put aluminium-foil tape.
So aluminium reflects up
to 95% of infrared light.
So it's really easy to
stop the laser pulses.
And laser cleaning is very different
to traditional cleaning
methods for removing soot.
Externally, they would
use high-pressure water.
Internally, on painted surfaces,
you're generally using a degreaser,
a bleach, countless rags, chemical gloves.
You'd be spraying the
chemical onto the surface,
be wiping it off,
and then you'd be using more cleaning rags
just until that surface was clean enough
that they could apply
another paint over the top.
Lasers are basically a single pass.
There's no water, there's
no chemicals getting used.
It's definitely the cleanest process
both internally and externally.
Laser cleaning's a brilliant technology.
It's really only getting started,
in the sense of being mobile.
So the technology is
really growing rapidly.
Every city in the world
is, in the next few years,
going to have a laser-cleaning company
that specifically targets smoke damage.
It's a good feeling to be
one of the first companies doing it
and doing it well.